I can redesign the world but what I do
well the first thing I do make far
better use of technology we're getting
at the moment well technology to get to
the marketplace at the moment a
scientist has to figure out there's
commercial potential in something they
have to give to set up the company they
have to go get it funded they have to
find the right CEO I have to get market
timing right and get it to market now
that's a lot of hurdles for one
technology together take a step back and
look at the global situation on one side
we've got a whole bunch of technologies
that we've developed over the last five
six thousand years on the other side
we've got call bunch of problems well
that's climate change and emic or
something more local like oil spills in
the Gulf of Mexico the problem is we're
not using technology to address these
issues as effectively as we should be we
want to change one thing that's what we
need to change